[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life
where we sift through philosophy to find
practical advice that you can use in
your
everyday life hi i'm dan hayes i'm
joined by my co-host dr greg sadler
today
we're talking about handling the
holidays during covid19
we're in the midst of a pandemic we've
got thanksgiving
and all the other december holidays
coming up and then of course there'll be
new years right around the bend
and it sounds like a lot of people want
to get together
for the holidays and that is both the
source of
perhaps a bit of comfort for some people
but a lot of grief and anxiety for
other people and so there's i guess
there's a lot of different issues here
that we wanted to put on the table but
we also think that philosophy
particularly practical philosophy
can be quite helpful in this time so
we're going to you know lay out what the
situation is and then we'll talk about
some tips some ideas some suggestions
that you could use exactly as dan has
said
not just your everyday life but your
your holiday day life right
and you know what little day we have it
is
you know the doldrums of winter at least
you're in the northern hemisphere
yeah you know one of the reasons why we
have
a lot of these um
celebrations at this point in time is it
kind of coincides with winter solstice
you know yule which has kind of taken
over for christmas and
you know the yuletide still is what we
call this
period at least for portions of like
europe and whatnot
um is all about like the
getting through these dark cold dreary
months
and what better way to do that but with
people
and the community that we as a social
species
really you know crave for but
unfortunately we have to kind of short
circuit these really
basic wants of being together
in the large groups that we usually
associate with this season
specifically because we love these
people it's kind of counterintuitive at
least in
one sense yeah i mean you can say that
it's challenging enough
living in covid 19 times with all the
economic dislocations and here in the
united states quite a few political
conflicts about
whether people should wear masks or
socially distance or whether covet is
even real or not in some places which
you know is
quite a striking thing to to be
happening in this 21st century of ours
but then you add to it everything that
you're you're talking about with the
you know the shortening of the days i
mean i you know i remember here in
in wisconsin when i was going to college
and there were quite a few people who
would work
um in the factories that
they wouldn't sometimes see the the sun
for days and days on end it was quite
quite hard on them you know
sads is a serious issue here so we've
got all those challenges and then we've
got
you know something that that seems kind
of a cause for optimism getting to see
our beloved friends and family again and
and now we take that away so but
we're not really taking it away right
it's about prudence
right it's you know
it there's definitely a portion of the
population that
doesn't see that
sees more um
blame in things that have more agency
and because
agent there is like no agency within
covet itself it is just a you know it's
a piece of rna
that just does a thing which happens to
also kill us
but it doesn't have like an agency
behind it
intending to kill it yeah and so there's
then the those people that are saying
you can't do
things and because they have more agency
and more intentionality
i guess it seems to be those people who
have a
more fundamentally conservative outlook
um
find more blame to give to those things
that actually have
agency and so i will tend to be more
angry at those people that are
imposing lockdowns or saying like this
is
what we need to do in order to fight
this thing so yeah and that i mean that
can lead to risks within families and
friend groups i've seen it
quite a bit where you know somebody's
saying so you're saying that we have to
do xyz
and and you know you might respond well
no no the cdc is telling us this is what
we ought to do
and then they're saying sisa well you're
one of them
you're you're imposing this as you're
saying uh
upon the the rest of people and and i
think when it comes to family
matters especially with thanksgiving
it's interesting talking with my
european and south african and
australian colleagues
all of them are like well you know we've
got the christmas season coming up and
we're getting ready for that
how we're going to get through that but
you americans you have thanksgiving
so you've got an extra blip on on the
the timeline that you have to be
concerned about
you know and and they all say it in sort
of a tone of voice that conveys
something like
oh you poor sobs
i mean in normal times it's really nice
to have
i mean it so here's here's like a little
bit of off-topic stuff
from a instructor's perspective as
somebody who teaches college
having thanksgiving in a normal year
means that we don't get any real work
done from students
except for final exams from thanksgiving
onward
because you know they go off on on
thanksgiving break and they they have a
good time and then they come back
and they're not really ready to do a lot
of work in those final week or two
of december before they take their their
final exam so you almost can write off
accomplishing anything i suppose you
could say similar things about a lot of
workplaces too right
right i guess it kind of depends on if
your work is
more atomic that you can just go and
like if you
work three hours and you've got three
units of work done right you get a
factory
that's still fine but yeah if you gotta
like do any like projects or whatnot
yeah
the amount of work goes yeah and then i
mean there's all the holiday parties and
stuff like that
sucking up time so you know but now
we're yeah we're in a very different
circumstance so this is this is a a
serious
challenge you know and and we've been
dealing with kovid now
how long um i mean march was the
beginning of the uh lockdowns so
seven months here yeah um
and so you know it's it's it's not
something that we're totally unused to
but i think a lot of people
want the holidays to be to be different
they want there to be
almost like a a release or get out of
jail car
free card or you know an exception to be
made
i don't know i don't know if i want this
exception well that's that's the issue
right
it's a struggle between rationality and
prudence
and what our what our desires are
and and though you know it's not as if
these are illegitimate desires
um wanting to get together with friends
and family
it makes sense so
um going back to
a point i was making just a moment ago
about
you know the agency of things and to
blame for it
um going to the dark arts of you know
advertising and social psychology
there's actually um a
technique of instead of
removing the agency from it or like not
give imbue covet with an agency and so
think of uh koben or tried to frame it
in the way of
oh it's a murderous little
bug that wants to specifically
kill your parents and grandparents and
it's going to use you
and your children to get to them so do
you
when when you see stuff um as i'm seeing
in social media where people are saying
um you know the the generation that went
through world war
ii they didn't get time off for
christmas or thanksgiving or
get to go back home um all you have to
do there's actually a great german ad
all you have to do is to like lie on the
couch and not go anywhere
can't you at least do that or you know
all you have to do is put on a mask is
that
is that an appeal to something kind of
similar this metaphor of
we're in a war with this this virus
um i don't think they're quite making
that direct it is a war i think it might
actually be useful
to defy to define it as a war like for
the longest time i thought
the idea of you know the war against
poverty
was just stupid uh marketing
but um it's actually
it's not for me it's not for me that
they're pointing to that it's more to
i guess to someone that has a little bit
more of a conservative mindset
more of a martial frame of mind or
um just the the idea of
the loyalty and to the group which is
um if you're familiar with um oh what is
that
jonathan hyde wrote a book about it but
he's not the only one that's written
about it um
called the uh the righteous mind
and it's oh yeah yeah i i remember that
go ahead moral
moral foundations theory that's the
basis of it and
um and so i think they're they're if you
look at generally they've got
like a group of people that can are
considered more
conservative and you've got a number of
way calls like taste buds
or faculties within the mind that can be
either turned up or down
how much you react to them and they are
your
disgust versus clown cleanliness
your loyalty your um
uh
fairness uh unfairness um and you're
oh i'm just like trying to pull these
out of there here uh that's that's
yeah that's it it's enough yeah and
and if you're either libertarian you
have like a couple that are
really high and others are low if you're
conservative some that are higher others
low and if you're liberally if some of
these are
and another is low everyone has all of
them and just
um of one of them that tend for those
people that tend to be more conservative
the one that one of them that is cranked
up higher than most of the others
is this loyalty one and that loyalty if
you can appeal to loyalty you can
bring people on on that might not agree
with you on everything and it seems to
be there is a
connection between loyalty as well as
that's interesting because i mean i to
begin with i i i've read
you know heights and i don't i don't buy
a lot of what they're
saying because i think a lot of it needs
to be highly qualified but
let's say we go with the assumption that
conservatives
the the way to appeal to them is through
loyalty we've got a problem
now in our highly polarized environment
because so many of them
feel like people who are are
further left to them aren't worth
loyalty
right and so you know i'm not sure that
that gives us the hook that we need
at this point in time i think it would
have been a really effective thing like
10 years ago and maybe the tea party has
ruined that for us
you know
a lot of unintended consequences yeah
but going back to this idea of like
using advertising
insights um are there are there any
other things that we could we could do
to get people to
take kovid and not gathering together in
huge groups and to see that
that sacrifice is being worthwhile to
take that as a live
possibility for themselves
right uh none that i can think of
offhand
uh yeah the the one of of
giving the agency so it's not just this
unagency thing versus people that are
making you do these things that you
don't like to do
yeah it's a very useful way to actually
make it give it some agency you know
draw it with little face and things and
whatnot and say this things wants to
hurt your parents and your grandparents
yeah
i remember when when i was little they
did that with tornadoes
oh yeah and they had these comic books
where there was like
and i don't remember how this worked out
but there was like a good tornado and
there were all these bad tornadoes
and the comic books were basically to
teach you what to do in case of a
tornado
you know we get quite a few of them here
in wisconsin and
tornado drills are very common so like
you know how to get under your bed and
you know go to find the basement and you
know don't like look out the window at
the tornado
things like that and and i think that by
depicting it with like you're saying
with agency and intentionality
it might have got it home to us dumb
kids a lot better
so maybe that's that's that's uh
quite helpful there you know i do want
to mention
some of the interesting surveys that
have been done that give us a bit of you
know
cause for for concern so interestingly
the big the big survey of course was
that 40 percent of u.s residents say
that they plan to gather in groups of 10
or more
during this holiday season that was a
survey from ohio state university
and nearly 33 percent of them said that
they wouldn't require friends or family
to wear masks and 25 percent
so they wouldn't practice social
distancing so that's a significant
number i mean let's say the numbers are
off by 10 percent
that's still enough to do a lot of
spreading over
thanksgiving and it's quite quite
worrisome and what do you do
this is part of what we're going to talk
about what do you do if your family
is mostly of that mindset do you
participate
to keep the peace do you say i think
this is a bad idea
but the other thing that i think was
kind of interesting survey wise was this
one that was done by supermarket news of
all places
and they said that nearly three-quarters
of us consumers aimed to spit
spend the same or more as last year for
thanksgiving items
with more than 80 saying it's important
to celebrate the holiday in spite of the
covet 19 pandemic so you know so far so
good right
they're going to spend money that's
great it keeps the economy going
and then they said 80 of those surveyed
said they planned to shop
in stores now the numbers don't
completely add up 19
said they would buy online for delivery
15 aim to use curbside pickup they were
allowed to use more than one purchasing
method
but if you know even if like 60 are
crowding into stores
that's not good you know right so i'm
so i don't what do you make of these
these polls
um you know tradition is
is very pulling and telling
and it is is just disheartening but
they do say that like if we if
the vast majority of us actually wore
masks and
kind of did proper social distancing
yeah like
uh there was a study i was just reading
um
yesterday so that if if 95 percent wore
masks and did
proper substitute dissonancing we
wouldn't have any more lockdowns but
i guess we just can't have nice things
and so
like yeah in one universe it's like okay
this isn't actually a problem because
people can
actually follow the rules well and do
these things but i also know people and
now what does that mean explain
um well i think everyone's know people
what is it um there's a great quote and
i might have quoted it here before from
men in black and j and k
are talking and and uh k tells jay
um there's the new rookie is like okay
a human is smart intelligent clever
um and calm people are panicky
scared
prone to violence it's like in the
aggregate like especially
as a group we can kind of go into a
little bit of mobility
and also as a group
we it's really hard to get everyone on
the same page
doing everything that is right
especially when there are
a lot of competing factors that are
sending bad information
about uh that this is even a
hoax that's not even real yeah
you know and it's hard to get people to
comply with rules even in
non-pandemic times when they don't have
a ton of stuff on their mind
but it's maybe it's even harder
sometimes to get people
ironically to take uh
real dangers as seriously you know
and if you go historically to the what
1918 spanish flu
yeah um there was uh
even anti-mass sentiment then that was
like the first time
that we had masks in the united states i
believe as a widespread thing
and there were like uh i don't know they
called them exactly anti-masks but they
made leagues of like
the unmasked um in order to fight the
oppression or
i'm not exactly sure yeah and i've seen
some of the propaganda stuff that was
used
and propaganda not in a pejorative sense
but that's just what they called it back
then to try to get people to wear masks
you know it was fairly primitive
advertising we had someone had good
good little rhymes or you know cartoons
or things like that
so so people are going to be faced with
all sorts of scenarios
um you you know you might have a family
group as we mentioned who want to do a
traditional get together or you might
even do friendsgiving
and maybe the friendsgiving group says
hey we're we're going to do it this year
regardless of the
um you know covid issue so
what do you do then you're kind of posed
with a dilemma you can say
i mean you could make up a lie and say
oh i'm sick
you know i can't go right um i suppose
so
you almost have a trilemma but you could
just say listen i don't think this is
safe and then
you know you're gonna get all these
responses from people that
are are pushback or you can go and just
kind of sweat the whole time that you're
there
and hope that hope for the best right
so that's that's not a great position to
be placed in
yeah you're either
doing something that you think is bad
for yourself or
uh you know you're juggling different
loyalties you have this group loyalty
that you have
yeah to your your family and or your
friends to go and do this thing with
them
versus this uh you know want to stay
healthy and also not potentially pass
things
and you have to i guess make that
decision for yourself
which ones are more important and if you
feel like your health is more important
then you better you know well i guess
you've got two options you can lie
or you can actually be truthful and
honest with these people
and and say exactly how you're feeling
and risk conflict and
and you know um hurt feelings and
isolation and being told that you're
overreacting all those sorts of things
so that leads to the second
thing you know maybe your group actually
says well we're going to be prudent
about this i mean your family
you said is a prime example my family is
as well
in a different way um you know we're
we're not getting together with with our
relatives i don't know that any of my
relatives are actually
getting together except in the
households that they they live in
um but then there's this um you know
you're you're alone on the holidays and
that kind of sucks too right
right um there's that that song um
i'll be home for christmas right and
it's such a sad song although we play it
as if it's a happy song
but it's a sand song because the person
doesn't make it home for christmas
they're only going to be home
in their dreams so we could we don't
have thanksgiving songs as far as i know
but we could have similar things for
thanksgiving too couldn't we
yeah uh and that that longing is there
and it's also there's a longing for me
to sing that song right now because it's
in my head
it's a catchy tune yeah it is i love it
yeah
you know and then there's all there's
other people that we could think about
too like
what's going to happen at retirement
homes or what's going to happen at
homeless shelters
i remember when i was in the army that
thanksgiving for those of us who were
on post overseas was kind of a big deal
you know they'd bring out a decent meal
for us as opposed to the normal stuff
that we'd eat
in the chow hall which wasn't terrible
but wasn't wasn't great
but they you know give us a real
thanksgiving meal
um what are they going to do are they
are people just going to have to be
isolated and on their own
in these these sort of circumstances
it's kind of tough to
to think about yeah like i i've in the
past
um gone and helped prep uh dinners for
thanksgiving for there's a big homeless
thing with the
salvation army that i've helped out in
the past and
yeah like those are great and i was
actually thinking about this a couple
days ago i was like are they gonna
like box them up and like send them off
and so you can like eat
you know not with everyone else but like
that's kind of like half the point of
thanksgiving is that
yeah sure i mean that's that is the
prudent thing to do right that
is the safe thing to do um but you're
right there's something
there's something lost that that sense
of connection to other people
but you know once again it's it's your
trade-offs it's like it's a health or
this you know feeling a connection that
we have and hopefully
we can get through this and you know the
vaccines are looking on the up at least
at the moment and
um you know next year may be a different
story
yeah i think next year about this time
it'll it'll certainly be a different
story i'm i'm hearing people
saying things like well maybe we'll get
to have easter this year
and that brings up another good good uh
sort of side question right
so there's all these other people who
have already made sacrifices
about particular religious holidays
diwali was just
you know going going on recently and we
can talk about
ramadan the breaking of the fast and we
can talk about
various high holy days for for jewish uh
denominations and you know we can also
talk about what happened at easter
easter was kind of a mixed bag
unfortunately because a lot of churches
didn't do what they were supposed to do
and so we can say well why is it that
people are supposed to
stay you know in these these very small
groups and not get together in big
family groups for these other religious
holidays but christmas is supposed to be
an exception or thanksgiving is supposed
to be an exception
it seems like if we want to honor the
sacrifices that other people have made
that that adds weight to the side of
not getting together um in in anything
other than very small groups for
for christmas or for um
for uh thanksgiving which is right
around the corner
yeah just kind of like think about it
it's you could
if you have a big gathering and
that potentially ends the life of one of
your loved ones
oh they get no more christmases
and we all yeah a
christmas now in order for many more in
the future
you know it's kind of like that uh i
know the marshmallow test although i
know that the marshmallow test is
fraught with
repeated replication exactly um but yeah
just the idea of delayed gratification
you know can you delay one year of
christmas
in order to have potentially many more
yeah i remember when i was a kid now
this is a bit off topic but i'll bring
it back
in in a second when i was
i don't know maybe nine years old or so
our dog lady got hit by a car
and hit hit pretty badly she was a she
was a black dog
she was running at night she got hit by
it by a car that
was probably going 25 to 30 miles an
hour totally destroyed her hip
and she she ran for about a hundred
yards before she dropped
and then i was there with her for about
you know an hour before
um they were able to get her to the to
the emergency vet and then once she was
at the emergency vet you know we're all
there with the the family
and um my dad came out with the
the vet and he said well we got a choice
we got to make
we can either you know put lady down and
we'll have christmas this year
or we can replace her hip and there
isn't going to be any any christmas this
year
and we didn't even think about it
because you know
myself i don't know what my mom did i
actually don't quite remember
she might she might have been well i
don't know about lady but me and my
sister we both like responded
immediately
we're fine with no christmas um and
i you know if you're willing to do that
for a dog why why not so much more for
an actual you know human person um now
it's not
quite so cut and dried is that right
because there's only so
it's a probability that somebody will
get sick but if you're big in a family
you know you're almost guaranteeing
somebody's going to get sick
right was i believe they had a uh they
made a map
recently with data about like
you know infection rates and right if
you go to a
gathering of x amount of people i think
it was like 5 10
15 20 like five person increments
to tell you what the probability that
someone there
was going to have it yeah it was done by
county by county right
right very interesting because the
results could be very
different from one county to the
neighboring county
yeah and so basically at least with in
wisconsin here where we're at
uh if you had a group of 30 people
there was like a 95 chance that someone
had coveted in it
everywhere in the state wow
that is sobering to to find that out
and i think it was 10 there was a 30
chance that
uh at least milwaukee yeah you know that
makes sense
um it's sort of like the thing with in a
class of any given size how many
people are gonna have the same birthday
and you say well how that's so unlikely
but
actually as the class gets bigger um the
odds go up
quite you know quite quickly so right
well we should before we jump into what
philosophy can can provide we've already
talked about some of the
challenges that are in front of people
and i think there's some that we should
talk about
that you know whether we have covet or
not
on the scene they're problematic for
people who are
away from their family or sometimes
problematic for people who are there
with their family we make movies about
this after all
um so what what do you think are some of
the biggest challenges of the
the holidays challenges
you know or or issues people are facing
like in respect to coven no taking covet
out of the out of the picture
i mean covet kind of adds a new wrinkle
to it though ah yes okay so yeah we're
talking about uh
social dynamics here between you know uh
it's your family but you don't really
get to choose your family and so a lot
of times you have people with
very different i guess potentially
religious or political views that can
cause
uh wrinkles within the conversations
um and you know some families are better
at it
this dealing with these things than
others you know sometimes
these things you know can turn into a
brawls versus
you know a a quiet
uh like i don't know non-verbal slight
resentment
like let's just not talk about that you
can also have just old beefs that have
nothing to do with
social issues or politics or stuff like
that that people just don't
either they don't bring up or they bring
up in ways that are
antagonistic and kind of poking at each
other you know it's
we often don't see these people for most
of the year and then we get together
with them
and that's probably the worst time to
try to you know fix family dynamics
that's something for the therapist's
office not not for the the dinner table
maybe
that's like um oh it reminds me of a
festivus airing of grievances
oh yeah yeah actually that's one of the
good things about festivus right
the holiday for the rest of us yes the
best of us for the rest of us
um good old uh what not your strength
uh frank costanza right right
yeah pizza strength yes um but yeah
i i definitely say like there's a
catharsis of like
getting things out there but is it
really the best to do it right in front
of everyone else and have
all your dirty laundry is that better to
actually you know sit in a more
calm environment maybe the two of you in
order that you can deal with your stuff
without having to worry about if you
your reputation is on the line with
everyone else in the family
that's true and also i guess you can say
this not of all
families here in wisconsin but quite a
few that you know at these occasions
people
do get liquored up and that probably
doesn't conduce to
um working things working old beefs
through
all that that well you know doesn't
doesn't lend a sense of proportion or
perspective to people
no although it may make them more
willing to talk about things
yeah does it but does it actually result
in
breakthroughs or benefits yeah and you
know and then we've got the other side
people
you know covet isn't the only way that
people can be isolated from their family
um you know people might be unable to
travel
you know other illnesses could stand in
the way
so yeah are
um there's also
sadness and loss of grief of those the
other people that aren't there anymore
and so that's always
yeah you know you know maybe your your
grandma died and you hadn't like thought
about it but now you're back together
and all of a sudden all those memories
come back of
you know oh god like the last time i saw
all of you guys was you know at
nana's funeral yeah and
you know a common complaint for
teenagers is that they feel kind of
isolated even in their family
it might just be a phase thing but you
know they don't they don't believe that
but that can be the case for so many of
us as adults as well
you know feeling like well i i know
these people but i don't really fit into
this this group
so that can be that could be troubling
um
kovid19 adds another particular wrinkle
even for those who want to downplay it
which is greater awareness of our
mortality
and i don't know that that's you know
the best
thing to mix into holidays so
it's maybe halloween but
not thanksgiving um
so yeah so should we talk about what
philosophy could
could do to help i do believe that would
be a great thing to talk about
so you know there's a number of
different things
before we jump into this i want to say
that we don't have to have like
everything figured out
in order to make some sort of progress
or
make a good right move or something like
that
and a lot of the the issues that we're
being faced with are
issues you could say of personal
development or
of ethics really when it comes down to
it and
ethical issues are always going to
involve some controversy you can't
expect people to
agree with you across the board because
that just doesn't happen
that's part of why people have to sort
of stake out stands
on them and think through them with
principles or
you know other other useful tests or
things like that
and you know it's also you might say
that there's an ethical imperative to be
well informed about
the matters that we're going to make
decisions about so covid would be
one of those matters right so
oh go ahead like one of the things that
we're talking about earlier was that
that dilemma that one has
when they have to weigh health versus
those social
expectations and how do we do this
it is you know ethics is to a certain
extent a
the study of what is the right thing to
do in the situation
and you know depending on your ethical
framework
you're going to maybe come to different
conclusions about this
but it is good to have an ethical
framework that you are happy applying
and it might not be perfect but at least
you have thought through that process
rather than just like
trying to make it up as you go along or
go with your gut or
because that's usually how you get in
trouble you know it's interesting there
was a venn diagram
i saw floating around a while back when
the covid
pandemic first started and it had three
circles
and one was for utilitarianism one was
for virtue ethics one was for deontology
you know three main approaches
in in normative ethics and
then somebody actually put together a
fourth one that had ethics of care as
well which is a
another ethics theory out there that we
typically teach when we're teaching like
business ethics or
biomedical ethics or any of those sort
of things and
they all coincided in one thing wear a
mask
it's you know so there are different
theories out there um
most of them are going to converge on
some
some basic things you know don't be a
jerk to people be fair
um if you make a commitment stick with
the commitment and they'll have
different reasonings like the
utilitarian will say
well this leads to the greatest you know
benefits overall you know we want to
maximize
positives minimize negatives the
deontologists will say listen buddy
rules are rules are rules you know
you've got to follow them
and the virtue ethics person will say
well what kind of person do you want to
be you want to be a schmuck
who doesn't follow through on stuff or
you want to be a decent you know
stand-up guy i mean they don't usually
use that in the academic
setting but you know
people recognize these basic traits but
they're all going to converge
on the same basic thing and i think
with with this you know we can remind
ourselves that
what is the key priority here it we we
can say well i want to be with my family
and have a good time
and you know feel like things are normal
again but that's
that's actually not the priority the
priority is keeping people safe during
a deadly pandemic and
you know we can have all sorts of other
motives but
those other motives might have to be you
know placed in the in the proverbial
back seat
right right uh
yeah and you know
these venn diagrams in in other
situations may come to divergent
positions
but in this one basically all the the
major
uh ethical frameworks come down to the
same conclusion here
yeah the one exception would be like
egoism which would say well do whatever
is to your benefit
and you can still say well from a
rational egoist perspective try not to
get yourself sick
right but it could be well i i like you
know
being with these people and i value that
more highly so screw everybody else you
know that that's a possibility but
that's kind of an outlier
there's a really great story oh go ahead
isn't there also from the like the
rational igos like
i care about my health in order to
maximize my health i should do the thing
that
max might make sure that other people
don't get sick because
then they are potential vectors to me
yeah and
that's that's to altruism through pure
selfishness that is where the breakdown
and the information stuff
is is so damaging right because you're
right from a rational legal perspective
once you accept that wearing masks and
socially distancing and you know
not going to huge you know
concerts or stuff like that or family
gatherings of 100 people
like a wedding for example once you
accept that
as basic reality
if you are a rational legalist you're
going to do that but we have a lot of
people who don't accept that as basic
reality and they're
they're almost i think in part because
of this desire to like everything should
go back to normal
whatever normal used to look like
they're almost at
at the other end like somebody with a
chip on their shoulder you know saying
um you're not going to control me i mean
you know when we have a
supreme court justice here in in
wisconsin calling wearing masks tyranny
that that really shows that that kind of
mindset
but there was a story i wanted to bring
up one that you're familiar with
uh and it has to do with this guy
epictetus who is a great stoic
philosopher and teacher
and he had a dad come to him i think you
know where this story is going
absolutely
so the dad um you know epictetus says to
him
how's fatherhood treating you and he's
oh it's awful you know my kid got sick
the other day
and i found it to be such a you know
unpleasant experience and epicness oh
tell me about that
and the dad says yeah i love my kids so
much i feel what what the greeks called
familial affection towards her
fellow storge and greek and i felt it so
much that i had to leave
and epitome wait wait you you left your
sick kid
and the dad said yeah that's how much i
love her and i fx we gotta think about
this for a second now now first of all
did the nurse leave
did your wife leave you know are you
gonna say that they didn't actually love
her
and then he says let's think about
whether this is the loving thing to do
to abandon your sick child who might die
um to go away because you feel this this
this you know whatever whatever it is
whatever it is that you're feeling it's
not familial affection it might be
anxiety it might be you know
depression something like that the the
loving thing to do would have been to
stay by her side
this is the opposite of that the loving
thing to do
the affectionate thing to do is to stay
the hell away from
these people who we love you know and
however difficult that may be we really
have to do it especially for the ones
who are you know immune compromised you
know the older ones
the ones who maybe don't take
precautions
as often as they should we it's it's
tough to do but that is the
i think the affectionate thing to do
which shows us that
these uh philosophical stories you know
sometimes we have to think of what's the
principle involved right
and in this case like i guess
epithelius is arguing to this father
like what what is an excellent father
an excellent father someone who runs
away
from his child in their time of need
because they felt bad seeing their child
in a time of need it's like no you gotta
go
and and do what a great father does and
in this case
we are your family is like what does a
good family member do
what what are like the main things it is
to be
the family member to yeah support at
least very much
don't hurt your family member uh and
if you are doing things that are you
know okay
think of it in a different context
you've got your sister
uh sitting in your front seat with you
and you're driving drunk
you are doing something rather dangerous
and not only are you putting your life
in danger but you're also putting
your sister's life in danger yeah and
everyone reacts very negatively like
that
you reacted very negative to that
situation as i presented it
and i think it really like that is a
very analogous situation here that
interesting yeah yeah i see that keep
going
yeah that uh we
are bringing potential harm like yeah
you could drive home drunk and you could
potentially get home
safe and sound and nothing happens did
you do the right action there
even though that there's no actual bad
that came out of this
um you know what a what would an
actual excellent brother do you know
call a cab call an uber uh sleep in your
truck or something or whatever
don't drive your your one of your loved
ones home
in a way that could potentially kill you
and them yeah and so you bring up
something there
that comes out of uh stoic ethics which
is role ethics
and it's not only found in stoic ethics
but you know it's particularly
pronounced there
this idea uh as epictetus says you can
identify what your responsibilities are
by looking at the names of the
relationships that you have
so like you said you know what does it
mean to be a good father
you know or what does it mean to be a
good friend or a good sibling
good family member i guess we could say
this too about like what is it like for
me living
in an apartment building what does it
mean to be a good neighbor
um in terms of like where whether we
wear masks in the common areas and
socially distance they they just
actually put down a bunch of
footprints in in our elevators and halls
and stuff like that
and parka's people weren't taking it
seriously like they're supposed to
and so this is what six feet looks like
you know so
following following through on that yeah
and so that would stand in the way of
participating in these big family
celebrations
um you know i guess we should move on to
talking about so let's say you're going
to do the right thing you're not going
to go to the things
it does suck you you don't get to see
people who you
you love and want to see how do you
how do you handle that time on your own
what
what are what are ways that you can
still be
connected with other people or make good
use of that time or
and there's a number of ways to keep
connected with your family we don't need
to physically be with each other all the
time
especially now we live in a world in
which
technology is abundant with new ways to
keep ourselves
closer than ever like yeah it's there's
still a
a level of granularity that is not there
like when
you and i you know speak we haven't seen
each other for months
that's true yeah yeah we haven't been in
the same place since
february right yeah uh did one last show
at the radio station and then we're gone
and so
you know but you know i see you every
two weeks or so and i there's definitely
a feeling of camaraderie with you and we
can do this with our families i've i've
done
uh lots of zooms and other video
conferencing with lots of people
that i'm close to and i do them
regularly and it really does
scratch that ditch not all the way but
good enough
yeah and so i think that's a key element
to it that good enough
that being willing to accept not having
everything be perfect or everything be
ideal
um you know and and there's ways like
you said around us that we can use
digital
media to do it some families have talked
about like trying to have a thanksgiving
meal together
and then somebody else came along and
said you know
watching everybody stuffing their face
and and trying to have a conversation
while you're you're chomping down on
stuff maybe that's not the best thing
maybe you should have a digital dessert
you know or
a toast or something like that but let
the eating happen
off camera right nobody needs to be
looking at
each person chomping out away on
on things uh you know people might also
get jealous about not having you know
the the the great uh in in my family's
case you know the great tootsie eye the
meat pie that
some people make i can't make it here so
i would you know
feel twinge of envy um but dessert you
know
anybody can supply dessert and you could
have drinks or
whatever it is that you're going to do
and then then you can chat then you can
catch up then you could have that
conversation um i mean if it was going
to be watching the game i suppose you
could watch the game together
yeah absolutely and
if you are very very technologically
declined
on virtual reality and some of the
things like
yard chat and there's a number of others
that allow you to have physical presence
with within a space and see people
is another level up of granularity still
not all the way there
um but it's it's very interesting and
you can be whoever you want
yeah i mean when the vr gets to the
point where we can taste things
that'll be amazing won't it uh
i don't ever think that you're gonna get
a really good like something to stick on
your tongue
but uh so i think nasberries are never
going to taste like snozzberries
[Laughter]
no they are not um except
for uh things like maybe neuralink i
think that's the only time that you're
gonna get to where you're
instead of actually you know changing
the receptors on your tongue
right you're changing the neurons in
your brain saying this should taste like
blueberry or snozzberry or
yeah i mean this is totally off topic
but it would be
with the tongue thing we know that the
taste map was was actually
nonsense right um and it's way more
complicated than that
and we do have these these receptors for
things but we also have to worry about
mouth
feel and i don't know how you capture
the fattiness of a steak or something
like that but i mean again we don't have
to have it perfect it can be
good enough so so how do you handle um
how do you
the family thing is over how do you
handle being on your own and being
sad and lonely uh missing the people
that you want to be with
what what what does philosophy have to
help us with
i mean you can read philosophy to take
your mind off of it i don't know that
that's a great solution
but there's only so many things to read
in the world and i guess we have
an incredible amount of stuff to read at
our disposal
but it is very useful to be able to
deal with yourself to actually be happy
with yourself and your mind and
instead of just constantly filling our
ears and our eyes with
movies and podcasts and music to sit and
actually be
with ourselves and that is a
a cultivated skill uh that
can actually bring incredible benefit so
are you talking about
being with ourselves with by by reading
philosophy books are you talking about
being
with ourselves without like bringing
some
some other object into it uh i say
both here this is i guess a big tent but
you can okay
be with yourself and and read and think
about things
but if you're just reading then you're
never sitting with the thoughts
and so uh you to
to write down your thoughts or to you
know
take in some of the the meditation um
practices mindfulness meditation and
meta meditation
um other out there to actually start to
investigate your own mind's eye your own
consciousness how it works
and you know sometimes you deal with
those things
that would bother you
that you are drowning out yeah so taking
some
some time some unstructured time to
think about things or to
figure out what's what's going on in
your life that's the you know
rainer maria rilke calls that solitude
ein zamkite
being being literally on your own a word
that we can also translate is loneliness
um but it's possible to do that without
being lonely
and with him it's not you know there's
um there's a sense in which we can do
this
out in nature you know he says get to
know the things of nature
he's actually writing to a guy who's
stuck in too much nature in his letters
to a young poet
he's writing to this young would-be poet
who's actually a
um i think austrian army officer stuck
way out in the sticks
you know and what we would probably
consider beautiful mountain area but
he's like
i can't stand this place and rilka says
no no get you know
look at it check out the the nature
that's there but also go within think
about your childhood you know your
childhood
and the memories that you have are an
incredible resource and you know
the solitude can be painful and the
solitude can be
difficult but that's because you're
letting it grow it like
like you know opening up a space inside
of you and it can be done in the heart
of a vast
city because rilka did it in paris of
uh you know his his time he was actually
a secretary to rodan
and going you know rodin was in paris so
that's where he had to go
for that um and i think there's a lot of
different
um converging spiritual traditions that
that give us ideas about how to handle
being on our own and it's it's
interesting that we use
you know solitary confinement as a
punishment within
our prison system here at the united
states
which is considered a torture in many
other countries and it's outlawed
but and it's really
it's only a torture if you
um don't know how to cultivate
that self and that that solitude within
yourself and
yeah and it's interesting from my own
practice of meditation to sit
and you when you brought up paris and
maybe think of
um like all the noises of a city and
when i sit
here and like you know what uh regularly
i'll hear
cars drive by in front or i'll hear an
ambulance drive down the street
uh the busy street that's not too far
from me and
and you get to like uh understand that
these are just sensations
of the mind that they exist only within
your mind
that they are you know outside they're
just you know
pressure waves of air against your
eardrums and
only once they actually hit ear drums do
they become
a sound in which we can understand and
so that
that is just a signal that is hitting
our brain and so it is not
the thing in and of itself it is not the
siren
it is our perception of that siren and
so all these things that we like think
like oh that's you know that's
the cat yelling or that's the good the
car driving too loud with the
the music going on and it's like all
these things are just yeah
they they're things they're they're
signals that have happened to
come upon my consciousness and
they are only annoying or
bothersome if i define them to be
annoying or bothersome
i was just laughing because i was
thinking about another sound a cat could
make which
so many cat owners know which is you
know throwing up in the middle of the
night right
but even that you could be like oh this
cat's doing it again or you could be
like
that's you know that's the nature of
cats and you know now i have the
opportunity to
do something you know go over and clean
it up it's not that big of a deal
um and i think we could look at so we
could extend that as kind of a
jumping off of a silly point but we
could extend that to you know
being faced with this situation opens up
opportunities to
us to do things in different ways you
know
our families have traditions usually and
even friend groups have traditions and
those traditions seem like they're being
broken
by our non-physical involvement
right but maybe it's time that we make
new traditions i
i really like you know there was this
great uh set of suggestions in
in a reddit about covid19 support
about how you can still be with your
your family and
you know they talked about do things by
zoom or skype but i like
some of these other things like make
holiday cards
how often do we actually do that i mean
maybe this is the year to do that and
mail them off
or you know sponsoring a local
child or getting a friend a gift that
you know that they'd love
probably have to ship it you know rather
than go to the store to get it
but you know those those are things that
we can we can do
i think that we have a lot of
opportunities here for doing
doing something that could be productive
that could represent
progress on our part right
uh maybe we should go to the practice
here
yeah so this is something
again we've been talking a lot about
things where there's there's a
convergence between different
ethical theories or spiritual traditions
or philosophical approaches right so
this is one where there's
a lot of different philosophers and
wisdom traditions that have said that
you ought to do this
when you're thinking about what you're
going to do consider what you're
actually setting your hand to
get yourself clear about what you're
getting yourself into if you're going to
go to a family gathering
you know prepare ahead of time so you're
not taken aback when people
come up and start hugging you you know
you don't you don't freak out
if you're going to do that that's
probably something that that you should
be prepared for
if you're not cool with that then you
know maybe don't go to the family
gathering or get a sign that says no
hugs please or
something along those lines and same
thing if you're going to be on your own
maybe it's a good time you know to start
thinking before
the actual holidays happen how am i
going to get
through the holidays start looking
around for resources start
start accumulating ideas about what
you're going to do
start making some good plans for
yourself start
finding out uh what technology your
family is familiar with
so that you can corral them into a skype
call or a zoom
call or a google meet call or whatever
whatever it's going to be
whatever form of video conferencing um
there's also freeconferencecall.com
which we used
years back which is kind of nice you
probably know a whole bunch of them
you know i'm guessing right uh yeah
they're plentiful on the net nowadays
yeah
what i mean what what else would you say
people need to
think ahead about to to plan out ahead
of time
if you're physically going i'd say hmm
uh maybe a bubble suit
[Laughter]
um heck you could uh you know they've
got those
those blow up t-rex costumes and they've
got a number of like blow-up costumes
nowadays
true yeah you could potentially you know
have a family gathering but everyone has
to wear a blow up costume
it would be pretty hot though it would
be well you could have it outside
those things are kind of clumsy too
people be knocking things off the table
yeah well that's actually a good idea
yeah that could work
all right well it seems like we're at
the end so we've got
one quote to leave you with from you
know good old friedrich nietzsche
yeah he and he knows something about
solitude too oh yeah
uh he him and his horse right uh much
later
yeah he who has a why to live
can bear any how
[Music]
you